[Musique]
ça change quand même beaucoup de choses
sur obligé d'aller fumer le cigare
ailleurs dans au fond à gauche la pop
vous connaissez tous et plus dans la
benne billets sans fin
mais vous avez changé quelque chose
alors à votre façon de vivre
ah bah non c'est à dire que c'est lui
qui entrera dans la dot surtout on va
pas tous transformés pour lui au
contraire c'est à lui à s'habituer à
notre vie je pense enfin il ya quand
même des pannes lors de leur tournée
effectivement certaines vedettes font
participer leurs enfants leur vie
publique qu'est ce qu'on dira de faire
moi je suis pas au jeu le partizan du
contraire parce que je trouve que enfin
une offense et mutilé la vie la plus
normale possible
entièrement d'accord
je ne parlais il ya quelques années
jacques dutronc vous avez senti n'y vous
avez inventé un piège à filles mais est
ce que j'allais transmettre ce secret
est votre vie on leur en dit est ce que
vous avez bien sûr j'espère je vous dis
pas je voulais je voulais le vendre et
en fait j'ai gardé je pense qu'il s'en
servira c'est pas du tout usage qu il
ait pas rouillé du tout et ça marchera
sur 20 et puis peut-être que je serais
pas si vieux que ça à l'époque où il
s'en servira on pourra toujours se
[Musique]